what we're going to explore in this
video are polyhedra
polyhedra which is just the plural of a
polyhedron and a polyhedron is a
three-dimensional shape that has flat
surfaces and straight edges so for
example a cube is a polyhedron
a cube is a polyhedron
all the surfaces are flat
all the surfaces are flat and all of the
edges all of the edges are straight so
this right over here
is a polyhedron once again polyhedra is
plural polyhedron is when you have one
of them this is a polyhedron a
rectangular pyramid is a polyhedron so
let me draw that i'll make this one a
little bit more transparent and i'll do
this in a different color just for fun
i'll make it a
magenta rectangular pyramid
so once again here i have one flat
surface and then i'm going to have
four
four triangular flat surfaces
so this right over here this is a
rectangular pyramid
now it's clearly looks like a pyramid
why is it called a rectangular pyramid
because the base right over here is a
rectangle so these are just a few
examples of polyhedra
now what i want to think about are nets
of polyhedra and actually let me draw
and make this transparent too so we get
full appreciation of the entire
polyhedra polyhedron this entire cube
so now let's think about nets of
polyhedron
nets so what is a net
of a polyhedron
well that one way to think about is if
you kind of viewed this as made up of
cardboard and you were to unfold it in
some way so it would become flat or
another way of thinking about it is if
you were to cut out some cardboard or
some paper and you wanted to fold it up
into one of these figures how would you
go about doing it and each of these
polyhedra has multiple different nets
that you could create so it can be
folded up into this three-dimensional
figure so let's let's take an example
and maybe the simplest example would be
a cube like this
and i'm going to color code it so let's
say that the bottom of this cube the
bottom of this cube was this green color
and so i can represent it like this
that's the bottom of the cube
it's that green color
now let's say that this back surface
of the cube
is orange well i could represent it
like this and notice i've kind of folded
it out i'm folding it out and so if i
were to flatten it out it would look
like this would look
like that
now
this other back side i'll shade it in
yellow this other back side right over
here i could fold it backwards and keep
it connected along this edge keep it
connected along this edge fold it
backwards it would look like this
it would look like that i think you get
the general idea here and just to make
be clear this edge right over here is
this edge right over there
now i have to worry about this top part
the top part of the cube
maybe it is in let me do it in a pink
color
this top part of the cube
is in this pink color and it needs to be
attached to one of these sides i could
attach it to this side or this side
let's attach it over here so let's say
it's attached to that yellow side back
here so that when we fold it out when we
really unpack the thing so we folded
that yellow part back then we're folding
this part back then it would be right
over here
it would be
right over there and then we could fold
we could fold this front face
this front face right over here we could
fold that out
and this along this edge and it would go
right over there
it would go right over there and then we
have one face of the cube left
we have this side
right over here and we could well we
could do actually several things we
could fold it out along this edge and
then we would draw the we would draw the
surface right over there or
or if we want to do something
interesting we could fold it out
we could fold this out along the edge
that shares with the yellow that back
side so we could fold it out like this
so if we folded it out like this it
would be connected to the yellow square
right over here so you see that there's
many many ways there's many many ways to
construct a net or a net that when you
fold it all back up will turn into this
polyhedron in this case a cube let's do
one more example let's do the
rectangular pyramid because all of these
had all of these had rectangles or in
particular these had squares as our
surfaces
now the most obvious one might be to
start with your base right over here
start with your base
and then take
the different sides and then just fold
them straight out so for example we
could take this side right over here
fold it out and it would look like
it would look like that
we could take
this side back here
and once again just fold it out
fold it
fold it out it'll look like
that it should be the same size as that
orange side but i'm hand drawing it so
it's not going to be perfect
so that's that right over there
and then you could take this front side
right over here and once again fold it
out along this edge so it would look
like this
and then finally you could take
this side right over here
and once again fold it out along this
edge and it would go
right there
but this isn't the only net for this
rectangular pyramid there's other
options for example just explore one of
them instead of folding that green side
out that way
instead
instead we might have wanted to fold it
out along this edge along this edge with
the yellow side that you can see
actually let's make it a little bit
different let's fold it out along this
side since we can see the edge and let
me label let me color the edge so this
is the edge right over here on the blue
triangle so this is the edge when you
fold the green triangle out it would
look like this
if you fold the green triangle out
it would look like this so hopefully
this gives you an appreciation this
gives you appreciation there's multiple
ways to unfold these three dimensional
figures these polyhedra or multiple ways
to if you wanted to do a cardboard
cutout and then fold things back
together to construct them and these
flattened versions of them these things
these these these unpacking of these
polyhedra we call nets